This lecture is about the natural language content analysis.
Natural language content analysis is the
foundation of text mining.
So we are going to first talk about this.
And in particular, natural language
processing.
with a factor how we can represent text
data?
And this determines what algorithms can
be used to analyze and mine text data.
We're going to take a look at the basic
concepts in natural language first.
I'm going to explain these concepts
using a simple example that you are
seeing here.
A dog is chasing a boy on the
playground.
Now this is a very simple sentence.
When we read such a sentence, we
don't have to think about it to get
meaning of it.
But when a computer has to understand
the sentence, the computer has to go
through several steps.
First, the computer needs to know what
are the words, how to segment the
words.
In English this is very easy as we can
just look at the space and then the
computer would need to know the
categories of these words, syntactical
categories.
So for example Dog is a noun, chasing
is the verb, boy is another noun, etc.
And this is called a lexical analysis.
In particular tagging these words with
these syntactic categories is called a
part of speech tagging.
After that, the computer also needs to
figure out the relation between these
words.
So A and the dog will form a noun
phrase.
On the playground would be a
prepositional phrase, etc.
And there are certain way for them to
be connected together in order to
generate the meaning.
Some other combinations may not make
sense.
And this .....
This is called syntactic parsing.
Or syntactical analysis or parsing of
natural language sentence.
The outcome is parse tree that you're
seeing here.
That tells us a structure of the
sentence so that we know how we can
interpret the sentence.
But this is not semantics yet.
So in order to get the meeting would
have to map these phrases and these
structures into some real world
entities that we have in our mind.
So dog is a concept that we know an A
boy, the concept that we know.
So connecting these phrases with what
we know is understanding.
For computer, would have to formally
represent these entities by using
symbols.
So dog d1 means d1 is a dog,
boy b1 means b1 refers to a boy, etc.
And we also represented the chasing
action as a predicate.
So chasing is predic here with three
arguments, d1, b1 and
p1,
which is a playground, right?
So this is a formal representation of
the semantics of this sentence.
Once we reach that level of
understanding, we might also make
inferences.
For example, if we assume there's a
rule that says if someone is being
chased than a person can get scared,
then we can infer this boy might be
scared.
This is the inferred meaning based on our
additional knowledge.
And finally, we might even further to
infer... might further infer what
This sentence is requesting or why the
person who said the sentence is saying
this sentence.
And so this has to do with
understanding the purpose of saying
this sentence, and this is called
SPEECH Act analysis or pragmatic
analysis.
Which refers to the use of language.
So in this case, person saying this
might be reminding another person to
bring back the dog.
So this means when saying a sentence,
the person actually takes the action.
So the action here is to make a
request.
Now, this slide clearly shows that in order to
really understand the sentence, there
are a lot of things that the computer
has to do now.
In general, it's very hard for the
computer to do everything, especially
if we wanted to do everything
correctly.
This is the very difficult.
Now the main reason why a natural
language processing is very difficult
because it's designed to make human
communications efficient.
As a result, for example, we omit a lot
of common sense knowledge.
Because we assume all the..... all of us
have this knowledge, there's no need to
encode this knowledge.
And that makes communication efficient.
We also keep a lot of ambiguities,
like ambiguities of words.
And this is again because we assume that we
have the ability to disambiguate a word,
so there's no problem with having the
same word to mean, possibly different
things in different context.
Yet, for a computer this would be very
difficult because the computer does not
have the common sense knowledge that we
do, so the computer would be confused
indeed, and this makes it hard for
natural language processing.
Indeed, it makes it very hard for every
step in the slide that I showed you
earlier.
Ambiguity is a main killer, meaning that in
every step there are multiple choices
and the computer would have to decide
what's the right choice and that
decision can be very difficult, as you
will see also in a moment.
And in general we need common sense
reasoning.
In order to fully understand the
natural language and computers today
don't yet have that, and that's why
it's very hard for computers to
precisely understanding natural
language
at this point. so here are some
specific examples of challenges.
Think about the word level ambiguity
a word like design can be a noun or a
verb, so we've got ambiguous part of
speech tag.
Root has also multiple meanings.
It can be of mathematical sense, like
in square root.
Or it can be the root of a plant.
Syntactic ambiguity refers to different
interpretations of the
sentence in terms of structures.
So for example, natural language
processing can actually be interpreted
in two ways.
So one is.
The ordinary meaning that we will be
getting.
As well talking about this topic so
it's processing of natural language.
But there is also another possible
interpretation, which is to say
language processing is natural.
Now we don't generally have this
problem, but imagine for once a
computer to determine the structure,
the computer would actually have to
make a choice between the two.
Another classic example is a man saw a
boy with a telescope.
This ambiguity lies in
the question who had the telescope. This  is
called a prepositional phrase
attachment ambiguity meaning... where to
attach this prepositional phrase with a
telescope?
Should it modify the boy or should it
be modifying saw, the verb?
Another problem Anaphora resolution
"John
persuaded Bill to buy a TV for
himself."
Does himself referred to John or Bill?
Pre supposition is another difficulty.
He has quit
Smoking implies that he smoked before
and we need to have such knowledge in
order to understand the languages.
Because of these problems, the state of
the art natural language processing
techniques cannot do anything
perfectly, even for the simplest part
of speech tagging, we still cannot
solve the whole problem.
The accuracy that I listed here just
about 97% was just taken from some
studies earlier, and these studies
obviously have to be using particular
datasets, so the numbers here are not
really meaningful if you take it out of
the context of the data set that are used for
evaluation, but I show these numbers
may need to give you some sense about
the
accuracy or how well we can do things
like this.
It doesn't mean on any data set to the
accuracy will be precisely
97%.
But in general we can do part of speech
tagging fairly well, although not perfectly.
Parsing would be more difficult, but
for partial parsing, meaning to get
that some phrases correct, we can
probably achieve 90% or better
accuracy.
But to get the complete parse tree
correctly is still very very difficult.
For semantic analysis, we can also do
some aspects of semantic analysis,
particularly extraction of entities and
relations.
For example, recognizing this is the
person, that's the  location, this person and
that person met
in some place etc.
it can also do a word sense
disambiguation for some extent.
We can figure out the occurrence of
root in this sentence refers to the
mathematical sense etc.
Sentiment analysis is another aspect of
semantic analysis that we can do.
That means we can tag the sentences
general positive when it's talking
about product.
Or talking about the person.
Influence, however, is very hard and we
generally cannot do that for any big
domain, and it's only feasible for very
limited domain.
And that's a generally difficult
problem in artificial intelligence.
Speech Act analysis is also very
difficult, and we can only do this
properly for very specialized cases
with a lot of help from human.
To annotate enough data for the
computer to learn from.
So the slides also shows that computers
are far from being able to understand
natural language precisely, and that
also explains why the text mining
problem is difficult, because we cannot
rely on mechanical approaces or computational
methods to understand the language
precisely.
Therefore, we have to use whatever we
have today particular statistical
machine learning methods, or.
Statistical analysis methods to try to
get as much meaning out from the text
as possible.
And later you will see that there are
actually many such algorithms that can
indeed extract the interesting knowledge
from text, even though we cannot really
fully understand the meaning of all the
natural language sentences precisely.